lors du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à monsieur
rémi delattre
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
la situation sanitaire lié à l'épidémie
grippale est très préoccupante alors que
le pic épidémique n'est pas encore
atteint et malgré le professionnalisme
et la disponibilité des équipes
soignantes
on déplore deux lourds
dysfonctionnements avec des services
d'urgence saturé
bien sûr ceci nous interroge nous
interroger et nous inquiète
en termes de prise en charge des malades
en particulier les personnes âgées et au
delà de l'organisation hospitalière dans
sa globalité
cette situation doit vous conduire
madame la ministre à plus de modestie
vous qui vous glorifiez en permanence
d'un bilan qui serait pas fait ne vous
en déplaise à madame la ministre
tout n'est pas parfait non tout ne va
pas bien cette crise sanitaire et la
révélation de vos échecs en particulier
la coopération public privé
le manque de considération pour la
médecine de ville qui soulagerait
aujourd'hui avantageusement l'activité
hospitalière la prévention vaccinale
le taux de vaccination grippale est en
effet beaucoup trop faible tant pour la
population que pour les soignants non
tout ne va pas bien
suite aux alertes de santé publique
france vous n'avez pas anticiper une
prise en charge à la hauteur de l'enjeu
sanitaire que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
en fait dès octobre 2016 santé publique
france a indiqué que le virus de la
grippe 2016 2017 et est de type h3n2
proche de celui qui a contribué il y a
deux ans à une surmortalité de 18000
personnes
madame la ministre l'heure est grave
comment allez vous rassurer les français
qui ne comprennent pas cette situation
d'une part et des médecins et soignants
qui vivent très mal votre réaction
tardive pour gérer cet épisode hivernal
d'autre part
merci la part d'états madame marisol
touraine ministère des affaires sociales
et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
rémi delattre
c'est le 28 octobre dernier que le
ministère de la santé a activé la
cellule d'urgence sanitaire pour faire
face à la grippe et nous avons adressé
des recommandations régulièrement aux
médecins libéraux nous avons travaillé
avec l'ordre des médecins et nous avons
adressé des instructions aux hôpitaux
pour que semaines après semaines en
fonction de l'évolution de la grippe les
mesures nécessaires soit apporté
plusieurs hôpitaux près de 90 sont mises
en place des mesures spécifiques avant
noël pour répondre à l'afflux de
patients
aujourd'hui quelle est la situation il
n'y a pas davantage de personnes aux
urgences car nous atteignons le pic de
l'épidémie
en revanche une personne sur deux de
plus de 65 ans qui va aux urgences pour
la grippe doit être hospitalisé et il
s'agit donc de garantir qu'il y aura des
lits disponibles dans les jours qui
viennent et dans les semaines qui
viennent c'est pour cela que j'ai
demandé aux hôpitaux de garantir que les
actes qui ne sont pas urgents serait
reporté des programmes et pour que les
malades continuent d'être accueillis
dans de bonnes conditions mais je vous
le dit monsieur le député les hôpitaux
répondent présents le système de santé
fait face à la situation est toute
personne qui a besoin d'être soigné
l'est et toute personne qui étonne qui a
besoin d'être hospitalisés peut l'être
et il faudra expliquer monsieur le
député comment re supprimant 500 mille
fonctionnaires en faisant 20 milliards
d'économies
santé et en supprimant des hôpitaux de
proximité
alors que nous avons créé 31 mille
postes de soignants dans les hôpitaux et
investit 10 milliards d'euros dans les
hôpitaux
il faudra expliquer aux français
monsieur le député comment vous comptez
améliorer leur santé